this is Startalk I want to pick up with
Shep
on the event horizon telescope because
this is still a project under
development you're talking about we will
observe we hope to observe near these
two objects so first of all when do you
expect to start making these first
pictures of the black hole at the center
of our galaxy and why are you going to
do this good good questions so we
started off on the event horizon
telescope project by linking three radio
telescopes around the world together in
Hawaii in Arizona in California and the
first thing we realized was that the
supermassive black hole in the center of
our galaxy Sagittarius a star had a size
that was predicted by this shadow
feature so one hundred years ago
Einstein came up with this idea that a
black hole would cast a shadow and we
saw exactly that size that really got us
excited right because with only three
telescopes all we can do is tell the
size of the black hole now we want to
build instrumentation and put it all the
other telescopes that we can around the
world to fill in this earth sized
telescope and then we can make an image
it's the whole reason for doing this is
to look at the size and shape of that
shadow predicted again by Einstein to
test whether Einstein's theories break
down at the edge of a black hole and
also to study the dynamics of matter
around the black hole now will you
really be looking all the way at the
event horizon I mean after all light can
orbit a black hole but you know to
actually get all the way to the shadow
are you really seeing the event horizon
are you seeing a little bit further out
you see wind up seeing a little bit
further out there's something called the
last photon orbit and light as fast as
it goes
also is constrained orbit around the
black hole that's how deform the
space-time is it's a crazy crazy place
you could stand there with a flashlight
and look at the back of your head or you
could illuminate the back of your head
right and then it would bounce off your
head and your feet in front of you if
you're having a bad hair day you would
know it immediately that's because
that's what you're worried about when
you're you know right outside a black
hole yeah wouldn't your hair
automatically become bad just because
it's kind of you
is how much good you would see how bad
it was you think your hair feels gravity
more strongly
that's the spaghettification hair right
let me left behind would it kind of be
more frizzy or to be more like high
volume like what kind of shampoo would
you need to there might be special black
hole products I think we've just started
somebody right now is scratching out a
memo is there pharmaceutical company
something else willingness to be outside
a word about like more ways to oppress
women
what would have any limbs would you like
would study like be changed near black
hole how we met your fiery I was going
to endorse the haircut hair care
products but I'm not going to touch that
one